Movies go through a number of changes between
inception and the final cut that's released
in theaters, and sometimes the DVD will include
those scenes that were deleted or an alternate
ending.
There are many reasons the writers, producers,
or director may choose to go with a different
ending than the one that was originally planned
- whether because the first ending didn't
test well with audiences or the studio didn't
feel it would be appropriate for the movie.
No matter the reason, a movie's alternate
ending can give fans an idea of where the
film could have gone if certain changes hadn't
been made.
Here are Screen Rant's 10 amazing alternate
movie endings you've never seen.
Star Wars: Episode VI - Return of the Jedi
The final film in George Lucas' original Star
Wars trilogy received some backlash from fans
that appreciated the darker themes in Episode
V, especially due to Return of the Jedi's
inclusion of Ewoks.
However, according to the film's producer
Gary Katz, the original outline for Episode
VI had Han Solo dying in a raid on an Imperial
Base with a more "bittersweet and poignant"
ending.
But, Lucas decided the film needed a much
happier final act and Return of the Jedi was
overhauled.
Another reason Lucas didn't want any of the
main trio of heroes killed?
Toy sales.
Furious 7
One of the more tragic reasons that a film
would need to change its ending is the death
of a star, which happened to be the case for
Furious 7 when Paul Walker passed away in
the middle of filming.
The final cut of the film had Walker's character,
Brian, retiring with his family away from
the world of crime and street racing depicted
throughout the Fast and Furious series.
However, this was changed from early versions
of the script, which had Brian remaining part
of the crew led by Vin Diesel's Dominic Toretto,
and setting up future sequels.
But, as director James Wan explained, the
final ending made more sense in light Walker's
passing and it worked as a tribute to the
actor's involvement in the series.
X-Men: The Last Stand
The final instalment in the X-Men trilogy
of the 2000s has largely been seen as the
weakest of the three movies, trading massive
action set pieces for smaller character moments.
When The Last Stand was released on DVD, three
alternate ending scenes were included that
depicted a new school year at Xavier's Academy,
Rogue still with her powers, and Logan returning
to the bar from the first X-Men film.
However, during the scripting process there
was another major change to the entire third
act of The Last Stand.
According to director Brett Ratner, the original
script had the final standoff taking place
in Washington D.C. - with the Golden Gate
Bridge sequence occurring in the middle of
the film - but he urged the writers to change
it because too many other movies at the time
had used the country's capital city in their
final set pieces.
Scott Pilgrim vs the World
The trouble with basing a movie on a series
of comic books is that the source material
may not be complete at the same time as the
film.
That was the case with Edgar Wright's Scott
Pilgrim vs the World movie, which originally
ended with Scott and Ramona going their separate
ways while Scott got back together with his
high school-aged girlfriend, Knives.
Unsurprisingly, the original ending didn't
test well with audiences, but at the time,
that was how Bryan Lee O'Malley's comics had
left the characters.
Then, when the writer completed the series
with Scott and Ramona getting together, Wright
changed the ending to his film accordingly
- and audience scores went up.
Wright also later revealed that an early draft
of the script had Gideon Graves transforming
into a giant robot, but it was scrapped for
being too similar to Michael Bay's Transformers.
Chronicle
What happens when three teenagers accidentally
stumble into superhero-like powers?
Chronicle, from director Josh Trank and screenwriter
Max Landis, attempts to answer that question
as Matt is forced to fight his former friend,
Andrew, who takes a turn for the villainous.
The film ends with Matt promising to use his
powers for good from then on, but Landis'
original ending took a much more literal depiction
of super-heroics.
The original script had the film jumping ahead
two years to show a dam breaking in Asia,
with Matt swooping in to thunderous applause
from those about to drown.
He hypes the crowd even further - shouting
"F*** YEAH KOREA!" - then uses his telekinetic
powers to stop the giant wave of water.
Alien
Sigourney Weaver's role as Ridley Scott's
cat-loving action heroine Ripley has become
a fan favorite character in the Alien franchise
since the film was released in 1979.
But, one version of the ending would have
prevented Ripley from appearing in any of
the other movies in the series.
Scott had apparently discussed the idea of
having the xenomorph kill Ripley by biting
her head off, then recording a final entry
in her log by mimicking her voice.
However, the producers nixed the idea because
it was too dark and urged Scott to make sure
the creature died in the end.
We'll never know if Alien would have been
as successful if Scott had kept his original
ending, but we do know Ripley wouldn't be
the action hero we know today.
Interstellar
The ending of Christopher Nolan's 2014 space
and time travel film left many audience members
confused.
The final sequences see Cooper jettison into
a black hole hoping to send data to his daughter
on Earth, which he does through a 5th-dimensional
tesseract.
However, according to the director's brother
and screenwriting partner Jonathan Nolan,
that wasn't the original ending to the film.
The screenwriter said Interstellar first had
a "more straightforward" ending in which the
wormhole collapsed "when Cooper tries to send
the data back."
It's unclear how this event would specifically
change the ending, but it certainly seems
as though it wouldn't have confused quite
as many people in the audience.
Watchmen
Before Zack Snyder tackled the DC Comics Extended
Universe, he adapted Alan Moore's critically-acclaimed
Watchmen series.
The film was praised for its faithfulness
to Moore's comic, but an early version of
the film that had Terry Gilliam attached to
direct had a much different ending to both
Moore and Snyder's versions.
As revealed by producer Joel Silver, Gilliam's
Watchmen would have ended with Ozymandias
convincing Doctor Manhattan to go back in
time and stop himself from being created,
which would have changed all the present day
superheroes into people that simply dressed
up like heroes from comic books.
Snyder has since openly criticized Gilliam's
ending, though his film's final act was also
criticized for not exactly following the source
material.
The Hateful Eight
Quentin Tarantino's eighth feature film was
almost cancelled after the movie's original
script leaked online in January 2014.
But, the director held a stage reading of
the script with the entire cast, where they
announced the production would be moving forward
with some changes made to the story.
According to those that read the initial script
or saw the stage reading, Tarantino's original
ending had a much bloodier final act with
only Chris Mannix left alive - while in the
film he was joined by Major Marquis Warren.
Additionally, the violence and who kills who
in the final shootout was tweaked for the
film, likely to provide some surprises for
those that read the original script.
Kick-Ass 2
Another instance of a film being adapted from
a comic series that hadn't been completed
is the Kick-Ass series, based in the books
by Mark Millar and John Romita, Jr.
According to Kick-Ass 2 writer and director
Jeff Wadlow, Millar originally had the villain,
played in the movies by Christopher Mintz-Plasse,
die at the end of the second volume.
However, with a third installment to the movie
series in mind, Wadlow convinced Millar not
to kill the villain, and just leave him wounded
instead.
So, Millar's original ending would have prevented
Mintz-Plasse from returning to the series,
but since Kick-Ass 2 wasn't as well received
as the first film, a third movie may be out
of the cards anyway.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any alternate endings to your
favorite movies?
Let us know in our comment section and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one.